would you please be so kind to introduce
yourself to the audience of the nexus
musical will you come from wabasha
what's your background Travis a pleasure
to be here with you I am an American
philosopher my degrees are from Stanford
and Harvard where I worked with people
like Joe
Robert scale the great days
my career has been in Britain the chair
of philosophy of all the king's college
london
being in at the heartland of of Silicon
Valley Silicon Valley will that be part
of the problem or part of the solution
and comes time to have to check the
walls humanity is moving from its own
problems to its male the old problems
were prices of ignorance we didn't
understand the world well now manipulate
solid
300 years ago we didn't understand what
play mike dowda third have cities all
over
now we understand those kinds of
clavicus ignorance no longer
play to us
our new problems about crisis of
ignorance the crises of our own
computers are so powerful
so present so sick
we could hardly keep anything
our weapons are so light so devastating
you can climate change is a crisis
isn't it point
all of these machines that we will smoke
coming off
people living longer even better and
traveling the way to see the world to
see each other isn't it pointed that our
inventions avalanche
like really those are the places
the hard things not to do crisis
dads
how can we
all the blessings
this crew
what
how does that relate to the title of
this new book of you which I read with
great pleasure blocked by the strange
thing about our world
natural resources which should be a
let's open places first
one statistic just to sum it up
the progress in the developing world has
made last generation China India even
Africa's doing so
except the country's
countries that have oil or no
no free
that's sure
you can think Siri
all these countries are cursed by oil
very whole very bad rule pass
before
the rule that basically says oil might
makes right
my
so
when Gaddafi
took over Libya
the world started by
and then years later when rebel groups
to cover those same well see karate they
became greedy from all
rule says whoever has the most money
from the world and that money gets the
max
those things attached it never has to be
paid back and of course the power
people
have to watch what their research so
long
and money comes in
because to rebels or armed groups they
can use it to buy more weapons
it goes to an authoritarian
authoritarian can use it to buy the
muscle a world
the Saudis who get the world's one
and we can use that money to spread
their extreme intolerant version of this
law
that's the really smell
cut25 islands
least nature and also in Europe
is this also explanation how it is
possible though the only one end and
Saudi Arabia is the fertile ground for
so much extra Nestle spreading all over
the world in form of Isis and ordered
monsters at the same time it's now 8 for
2016 president obama is paying his
respects again to the king of saudi
arabia instead of standing up as he
could stand up against mr. Putin or
Qaddafi overlap in the short term that
always makes sense to do business as
usual the short term that always makes
sense to try to make an alliance with
the authoritarian regime how's that
going how's that strategy worked past 40
years
how did it work with Gaddafi that a
wooden cigar with a work
this year
I wasn't working to try to keep the
absolute power of
well in check
you just told us that you study the
powerpoint with the Great's professors
there Obama also wants us to depart for
the half of law school why is it did you
understand something he apparently
doesn't understand John Rawls said
politician looks to the next election
the state's level works to the next
generate
the philosopher looks to the permanent
conditions
politicians always have to look too
short it's up to us as philosophers and
citizens to look to the longer-term
interest and do we find out move for
waffle safe you'll tell us the clue to
saving the world is definite reception
so the rule is a terrible place to
violence extremism
but the world is a much better place we
really are living better
even 60 years ago
Richard good advisor longer do women
died in childbirth literacy rates as has
ever been more democracies in the world
than ever and shocking as it seems
post
both of these things are true
the world is terrible compared to what
it should be but it's better than it was
ways that will pass come and give us
solutions for the provost
food
it's so hard
to overcome their challenges which were
at least